now the Democrats like to portray
themselves as members of the enlightened
class they're the elites and
conservatives are the vulgarians so
Trump of course to them is the ultimate
know-nothing right I mean he's a guy who
shoots from the hip and the mouth he
hasn't marinated himself sufficiently in
the writings of let's say Aristotle and
Plato and he doesn't understand world
history or the complexity of geopolitics
he lacks compassion and is so so crass I
think if it's fair to note that the
president has is vulgar I mean is vulgar
has insulted Prime citizens he watches a
lot of cable television no matter what
he says but his lack of reading lack of
interest in reading is a big contrast to
our last two president he doesn't have
any empathy even for his recovering wife
he doesn't have any empathy for anyone
meanwhile the same left wingers who
climb Trump is a lowbrow ignoramus are
conspiring to make our children
something far worse in my mind not only
do today's liberals many of them hate
our American traditions and a lot of our
heritage but they're also the agents of
a historical and cultural purge the
likes of which I don't think we've ever
seen in our nation now you know what's
gotten bad when just this week leftist
librarians took it upon themselves to
strike Laura Ingalls Wilder's name from
a major children's book award the
American Library Association first
awarded the prize to Wilder herself back
in 1954 they later named it after her
but now the librarians claim that
Wilders work includes stereotypical
attitudes not consistent with values
regarding the depiction of Native
Americans now I think I'm right here but
little house was after all set in the
1800s in Minnesota so don't we want to
know how people in the past lived how
they thought and frankly how they
survived my view is if we hide or worse
demolish our history what do our
children go to learn the lessons of the
past
so I guess Mark Twain Truman Capote
Flannery O'Connor Harper Lee
in those other stereotypical writers
will also soon have to be banned as well
so who are the real book banners now
well I guess there's always those lovely
PC graphic novels kids now this is the
same leftist mentality that has led to
of course the destruction of historical
markers and statues all over the country
what amount to Marxist city councils
have ordered the removal of Confederate
monuments from public spaces removing
history altogether rather than allowing
the next generation to see it interpret
it and yes debate it now these official
acts i think of inspired left-wing
activists to take it upon themselves to
topple or deface statues which you know
for for good or for bad of course are
part of our national memory and by the
way i'm saying this as a Connecticut
Yankee I got no I got no affinity for
the south but it doesn't stop there
even this 1925 World War one cross
memorial in Maryland is now considered
offensive to militant atheists they
filed a suit to have the memorial
removed and the Fourth Circuit Court of
Appeals agreed with them and ordered the
peace crosses demolition so now who are
the intolerant Know Nothings again the
left
I would submit is so blinded dogmatic in
their ideology and their hatreds that
they refuse to accept even basic facts
sometimes scientific facts abortion is
but one example now they continue to
deny the obvious truth of human life in
the womb now far from an article of
faith religious understanding this is an
established scientific fact and we have
the pictures to prove it who can deny
that an ultrasound of a 12 week old
child preborn child in the womb is a
living human being growing and living
well but groups like Planned Parenthood
and the Democratic Party at large well
they're determined looking the other way
that I didn't like the fact that people
can see this mother's seeing these
images the visual evidence the proof of
life is the threat threat to the
abortion racket make hundreds of
millions of dollars on this don't look
the left is so anti debate so anti
dialogue that they prefer to intimidate
now and demonize their political
opponents rather than convince them
convinced that their arguments the right
one bring people along to your point of
view no no we're not gonna do that
instead they resort to slander or
labeling conservatives or Trump
supporters as remember Hillary called
them the deplorable x' obama said the
people clinging to their guns and their
religion now we've told you about those
2016 texts this all bleeds through the
process all the way down to FBI agents
working on the Hillary Clinton probe
once said that Trump supporters not
deplorable but they're all ports a
middle class uneducated lazy POS look it
up if you don't know what it means that
think he will magically grant them jobs
for doing nothing
another referred to his voters from Ohio
as quote [ __ ] nice no bias there but
sadly now it's gotten even worse because
we now know that we have in the White
House someone who could lead the Ku Klux
Klan in the United States of America
somebody who could be the leader of the
neo-nazi if you vote for Trump then you
the voter you not Donald Trump or
standing at the BART border like Nazis
go you hear you hear tens of millions of
people voted for him after he showed his
cards four years
what are you said we are you suggesting
that they're racist or ther yes they
admit the people who vote all the people
who voted for Donald Trump yes at least
are being honest now that's what they
always felt now they're actually saying
it so understand this by casting their
political opponents as a despicable
frankly subhuman class the left now has
a blanket license to attack them and
target them in public they're not going
to be able to go to a restaurant they're
not going to be able to stop at a gas
station they're not going to be able to
shop at a department store the people
are going to turn on them they go to
protest they're gonna absolutely harass
them until they decide that they're
going to tell the president no I can't
hang with you
ask them when they go into public places
surround crowd what does that lead to
well it's expected the leftist renegades
have absorbed this message from the
political class it's now open season on
conservatives activists are now papering
White House adviser Stephen Miller's
neighborhood in DC with wanted posters
barring Miller's image wanted posters
dreamville White House official like a
criminal to be hunted and captured
completely justified in their minds now
for months the left has been insisting
of course at the president's immigration
policies especially as travel ban was
unconstitutional they derided Trump in
his administration as racist for
attempting to prohibit immigration and
travel from certain volatile hotspots
same ones that Obama targeted as hot
spots himself now again the left refuses
to acknowledge basic truths basic facts
it's a national security threat and it's
posed by immigration from certain
regions in the world
we can't vet these people no systems in
place well the court today
weighed in not only ruling that the
president has the statutory authority to
control and regulate immigration frankly
it should have been a 9-0 case but that
the ban does not contain any religious
or anti-muslim bias the ruling shows
that all of the attacks from the media
and the Democrat politicians are wrong
and they turned out to be very wrong now
the left was stunned that the Supreme
Court sided with Trump on the travel ban
DNC Deputy Chair congressman keith
Ellison without so much as a even an
attempt at a glancing reference to
statutory interpretation he reacted this
way corsets really should not be on the
Supreme Court in my view he's he may he
may be there but he's not there properly
you know you know he you know you can do
that I mean in this you know you can you
can jam in a Supreme Court by denying a
sitting president fair right to appoint
the Supreme Court justice that is
exactly what happened and coarsest has
just done what his paymaster's sent him
there to do last part is key not a real
justice
he's just doing what his paymaster's
said to do guys a storied career as a
jurist on the federal court of appeals
so no legal rebuttal to the statutory
interpretation of the court no attempt
at a rational argument just personal
demonization of a Supreme Court justice
now in the 1850s America saw the rise of
the know-nothing party it was an
anti-immigrant an anti-catholic
political movement that sprang from what
was ultimately a secret society and
today we're seeing the rise of another
know-nothing party made up of secret
forces deployed to undermine the will of
the people and the representatives they
know nothing of facts nothing of history
and nothing of the damage that they're
doing now to the Republic they're called
Democrats and that's the angle